you
hello my name is danforth's I'm a
researcher in the systems research group
at Microsoft Research Redmond I lead the
Prometheus project which is about how to
take advantage of new hardware in the
data center co-designed with distributed
systems so what's motivating this is
that we are now in a world where there's
a wide variety of customized and
programmable hardware available in the
data center we're not just in a node era
where there are commodity servers
connected by a dumb network but we now
have programmable devices including / a
mobile data plane switches smart Nix and
FPGA is deployed in the network so what
that means is that there's the
possibility for the network itself to
act as a computational element to run
some amount of processing directly on
each packet and we're interested in this
from a systems perspective what can this
you how can this be used to accelerate
distributed systems applications the key
to our approach is that we're going to
Poe design Network primitives with
distributed systems to use this hardware
to implement some new functionality and
then build the applications around that
so to give some examples of this we're
able to build replicated systems that
are considerably faster because we don't
have to run a traditional consensus
protocol like Paxos on every operation
instead we can run a simple primitive in
the network that assigns sequence
numbers to requests as they come in and
then use a much simpler protocol that's
able to implement the replication
without the replicas having to talk to
each other and this lets us improve the
performance of a existing data center
service by a substantial amount we're
able to reduce systems from having an
80% overhead for replication to more
like 2% we are also investigating new
applications that require more
computationally intensive primitives so
for example deep neural network training
requires a lot of communication
bandwidth in today's highly parallel
clusters we're able to reduce this
communicate
overhead a lot by having the network
aggregate parameter updates from the
different servers combining them into a
single update rather than having the
full set of data be distributed to all
the servers and this is able to increase
the throughput of these neural network
training by 3x which will dramatically
reduce training time we're also looking
at other applications including load
balancing we're delivering different
requests to different servers based on
the load is able to increase the network
the the system utilization by a
considerable fraction without running
into tail latency problems Network
telemetry applications we're a part of
the processing is done in the network
switches themselves overall what we're
able to do with all of this is to build
systems with dramatically lower orders
of magnitude Oh latency and throughput
overhead by moving computational
elements into the switch and the key
part of this is to carefully think about
what primitives need to be deployed in
the network versus what needs to be done
at the application layer thank you
you